mettez-le dans
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai marre que les gens pensent que je suis une
sorte de blague ton père et j'ai convenu que ce
serait mieux si tu arrêtais d'être qui
tu es et de faire les choses que tu aimes
toute ma vie
tout ce que je voulais je  J'ai peur qu'on ait trouvé ton
fils à une soirée polka
c'est pour inventer de nouveaux mots pour une chanson qui
existe déjà
eh
bien tu devrais faire ça alors
mon petit affamé un affamé ouvre
un paquet
[Musique]
mec j'ai des frissons
tous les  de temps en temps
je peux repérer un talent
que je sais être l'avenir de la musique
mais d'abord nous devons te trouver un nom de scène
al yankovic c'est long c'est difficile à
prononcer donc je vais juste jeter
ça là-bas bizarre al
yankovic j'adore
je me demandais si tu allais faire
une parodie de ma chanson comme une vierge je suis
curieux c'est cette chanson
autobiographique oui
sauf le fait que j'ai eu beaucoup
de sexe
[Musique]
laisse moi un génie créatif qui ne  Je
n'ai pas un passé mouvementé impliquant de l'alcool
et des drogues
Je pense que Madonna a une mauvaise influence sur toi
quoi non  infraction
je suis un accident de train
mes parents m'ont radié j'ai repoussé mon
groupe vous n'êtes tous qu'un tas de normaux
je suis le bizarre tu dois prendre soin
de toi j'ai vu sur toi quelque chose de
spécial un artiste
avec quelque chose à  donner au
monde devant tous les milliards de personnes qui
regardent dans le monde en ce moment
tout ce que je veux dire c'est être aussi bizarre que vous
voulez être
vous ne trouverez jamais le vrai bonheur
donc vous pouvez vraiment accepter qui vous êtes
[Musique]
merci  toi
oh
tu ne peux pas fumer ici
je mérite totalement que tu sois